we were lucky we might just get out
alive
but what waited on the other side would
be possibly my toughest challenge yet
hello and welcome to Wang taint a
creepypasta horror stories cooked to
perfection with a splash of red sauce my
name is Suzy and today we'll be serving
you on the beach so kick back relax and
enjoy these vacation humor stories let's
dig right in
number one island adventure a woman at
the airport had asked me if I was
looking forward to my vacation to simply
say yes would have been an
understatement I had to work overtime
for five months in order to afford to
get here then I had to find time of work
and get off at the same time as my
boyfriend
we had to research the perfect resort on
the perfect island with the perfect
weather but we made it nothing else was
between me the warm tropical sunshine a
cold refreshing margarita and the
relaxing sound of waves crashing on the
sand in front of me and carelessly
rolling back out into the sea as I dug
my toes into the soft sand and laid back
on my beach chair I thought about all
the possibilities that awaited us here
at the grand Maritime Beach Resort
kayaking through the ocean breeze living
the high life at the offshore casino
backpacking the expansive rainforest by
moonlight or regenerating my body at the
luxury poolside spa maybe I'd even try
scuba diving though I wasn't sure I
liked the idea of breathing through a
tube I think before any of that though I
just kicked back on the beach and enjoy
some sunlight
we'd had a long trip and it felt good to
just drop our bags slip into a bikini
and take in the salt
water aroma I could feel myself starting
to fade off to Lucy Lucy you okay oh
yeah I just fell asleep what time is it
about two you were tired you looked dead
Thanks
I was just going up to the barn do you
want anything to drink you could grab me
a pina colada
I guess okay he kissed me and headed off
to the bar before I could goes off again
a strange little man came walking down
the beach with a clipboard he looked
like one of the locals a bit of an
oddball one at that
he went from chair to chair making his
way up to where I was when he arrived he
asked if I was interested in going on an
island adventure he explained that it
would include backpacking in the
rainforest ziplining roasting food by a
campfire and bathing in a private
waterfall grotto the clipboard included
photos of what looked like an absolutely
amazing time to me so I told him it
looked perfect and I wanted to sign my
boyfriend and I up for it he told me to
follow him down the beach to the
activity Shack so I can make a
reservation I dipped my feet in the
water as we strolled the length of the
shore but the man kept rushing me along
I didn't think much of it at the time
just assuming he was impatient that
should have been my first of many red
flags
next we walked off the property of the
resort I asked if the expedition was
included in the resort package he told
me it was and I had no reason to believe
otherwise we finally get down to the
little Hut all I remember was it being
completely empty and not really looking
like an activity Shack at all the guy
quickly apologized and told me that the
activity director must have already
headed up to the site to begin preparing
for the excursion I was starting to get
pretty annoyed at this point and told
him I better walk back and let my
boyfriend know but he assured me that
the site was just across the street and
it would only be a couple more minutes I
was reluctant but didn't want to be rude
since he insisted besides it would be
good for me to get to scope out where we
would be exploring so we made our way
inland I had to run across the street
barefoot no crosswalk this led us
directly into the rainforest and when we
got there I started to get a bad feeling
there was no set path we were following
he was just leading me deeper into the
forest the other thing that set me off
at this point was the complete lack of
other tourists I thought for sure we'd
see other couples signing up as well but
scratch that it wasn't just a lack of
other tourists it was a lack of people
there was nobody out here just me and
the sky who randomly approached me on
the beach I had no real idea that he
actually worked for the resort he was
kind of scraggly and unkempt certainly
not up to the standards of grooming we
had seen at the front desk but he did
look to be an island local like most of
the employees we had seen at the resort
and it's not like the island adventure
expedition wasn't advertised in the
brochures but something deep inside me
said that this wasn't the real thing
I got more and more nervous I was
honestly thinking about turning and
running
but the only thing that stopped me from
doing it was how embarrassing it would
be if this was legit because there was
still some doubt in my mind besides it's
not like I'd make it very far with no
shoes and no idea where I was going I
debated doing it anyway in my head when
something emerged in the distance
another man was standing out there
veiled by a layer of fog and facing
slightly away from us relief washed over
me when the guy I was with called out to
him in another language and the guy came
up to us realistically it was just a
couple minutes just as he had told me
back at the activity shack before I
could feel silly for doubting him the
two men went back and forth in their
native tongue I don't know what they
were saying obviously but I just know
they were talking very quickly but what
was weird was this new guy was staring
at me not making eye contact with the
other man actually he wasn't just
staring at me
he was eyeing my body up and down I felt
exposed and uncomfortable but let's face
it it wasn't the first guy that couldn't
keep his eyes off me it's just that
usually they try a little bit to hide it
he continued to fire off questions I
couldn't understand I looked up at the
rain forest we'd been exploring it
wasn't exactly as I pictured it how far
was the zip line where was the waterfall
that's when both of them went quiet
I looked back down at them both of them
were staring at me
I smiled sheepishly then the two men
simultaneously grabbed me I tried to
scream but one of their hands reached
over and muffled my mouth as both of
them dragged me down to the ground
I was completely helpless to resist with
the full weight of two bodies crushing
me a hand pinched my nose and closed my
nostrils tears began to flow but I
couldn't breathe
I was completely powerless there was
nothing I could do the black started to
envelop me from the corners of my vision
just before I blacked out I saw
something in a blur through my tears
deep in the distance there was a
third-person way back in the trees it
was the last thing I saw before the
black crashed in and I was out for the
second time that day I awoke in a haze I
thought I never would but I was alive it
was getting dark out but we were still
in the forest a different part of the
forest I didn't know how deep in we were
I actually couldn't make out much my
vision was a blur it was like looking
through beer goggles my right arm felt
dead almost impossible to lift but with
some effort I could move it around and
shoe off some of the hundreds of bugs
flying right over my body it didn't do
much good
they were everywhere the two men were
sitting by a campfire talking clearly
they hadn't noticed me wake up from what
I could tell they were about ten meters
away there was also a jeep parked nearby
too I felt as if I was hung over and
drunk at the same time but this was my
only chance to try to escape and I knew
it
there were just a few problems I had no
idea where I was how far we were from
the beach or from any civilization for
that matter
I was not in much condition to run I
still had no shoes and my bikini was not
great for running in to begin with
normally I might be more confident I do
jog for 45 minutes almost every day so I
had pretty good endurance I didn't know
what these two men were capable of
though and then there was that third guy
I had seen in the distance where was he
was he one of them was he going to be
patrolling the perimeter before I could
think of a plan
I saw them turn their back to me and go
to the car this was my chance i wobble
to my feet I didn't break into a full
sprint right away trying to strike a
balance between speed and stealth as I
got further from the campfire it got
very dark even just a few meters ahead
of me was starting to look pitch-black
it wasn't long before I stepped on
something hard and rough it rolled me
off my feet and I went crashing to the
ground
shoot I heard their yelling out in the
distance as they realized I was gone I
pulled myself to by feet feeling even
woozy er than before I heard the Jeep
start somewhere in the background the
headlights flared up behind me
so I scrambled my way up the nearest
bump in the terrain and ducked out
behind it doing my best
a muscle the area lit up as the vehicle
turned around and headed in my direction
it pretty much mowed over the low-lying
vegetation as a tor over the bumpy
terrain and headed straight for me
they didn't see me the Jeep passed and I
was safe for a little while longer
I figured I'd have to develop a strategy
so I could continue in one direction as
to not send myself in circles I decided
to go perpendicular to the way they had
just driven that way if they tried to
comb the area it will take them a long
time to get to me I got to my feet and
set off but then I heard something that
stopped me in my tracks
it wasn't loud I wasn't even entirely
sure I had heard it at all until I heard
it again there were footsteps probably a
good 30 meters or so my head was still
spinning and I couldn't exactly tell
which direction they were coming from
once again I had to reassess my
situation I looked around absolutely no
light
other than the faint moon's glow I
couldn't make out where the footsteps
were coming from or who they were coming
from what if only one of them had gotten
in the car or could this be that third
person I had seen in the distance it
could be a random person for all I knew
it might be worth calling out for help
but if it was one of them I didn't have
time to sit and think about it the
footsteps were getting louder I decided
to try and quietly move away it was
getting harder to get around though not
only was it dark but my vision was
swirling more and more it seemed like
the more ground I covered the louder the
other footsteps got the anxiety the
swirling headache the sick feeling I had
all of it was getting to me before I
knew what had happened
I collapsed I laid on the ground
breathing heavily the last thing I saw
this time was a pair of boots on the
ground in front of me they walked up and
stopped just before my face I couldn't
go on I felt myself start to fade once
again
number two international waters Bali
come on they're leaving I called back my
wife as she waddled down the dock and
her high heels what's the point I
thought to myself we were going to miss
it it was already 30 minutes past two
the boat should have left by now sure
enough just as we got to the end of the
dock the ship pulled away and headed out
to sea if only she hadn't taken so long
to get ready oh no shoot sorry Tom I
just missed it too come on we can still
enjoy the poolside bar for a few more
hours while the sun's still up I turned
back towards the mainland then I heard a
voice behind me it came from one of the
Island locals who was sitting at the end
of the pier apparently there was going
to be a smaller shuttle boat that would
take people out to the casino in about
an hour
perfect for us I made sure next time we
were waiting out there 15 minutes early
right at 3:00 p.m. the same guy from the
dock earlier pulled up at a tiny speed
boat he helped us aboard then once we
were seated he fired up the engine I
asked him if we were going to have to
wait for any other guests he told us we
were the only ones so just like that we
took off the sea breeze with Durer hair
as the island behind us got smaller and
smaller in the distance
Molly grabbed on to me for safety as we
looked into the sparkling horizon
eventually a speck appeared on that
horizon now long after that the speck
became a boat the boat upon which we'd
be spending the rest of our evening when
we walked in the place was popping
blackjack tables poker roulette a disco
ball bumpy to the beat of the bass and
bottle girls her every table couch and
lounge chair it looked like there were
more in the rooms beyond as well we
probably spent the first four hours in
this initial
I wasn't really keeping track of time
but that was more of an estimate based
on the amount of drinks me and my wife
had downed we jumped around from the
game to game spending some time together
and some apart I wanted to give one more
spin at the roulette table and I wasn't
sure where exactly [ __ ] right off to I
was getting kind of low on chips and I
wondered if she was doing any better
I noticed the guy next to me had a huge
stack of chips the most I had seen
anyone with the entire night I inquired
about where he had all the good luck and
he told me he made almost all of his
earnings in the private rooms he went on
to explain that the casino operates
offshore because what goes on in the
private rooms is very illegal but not in
international waters I asked if he had
any tips he told me to stay calm be
logical and don't do anything rash he
said you can make a lot of money there
but you have to know when it's a good
time to sit back and observe and when
it's a good time to punch and buy and
hai and the last thing he told me was
that that room was now for the
light-hearted or the morally righteous I
went to go find mom the first area
beyond the curtain door was a little
waiting area with a bouncer he asked us
if we wanted to play in a private room
and made sure that we knew we had to
stay for the duration of the game so if
we had to use the restroom to do it now
he reiterated but the one guy told me
about this being a moral ground zero
then we waited I hadn't noticed anyone
come out of the room but after we waited
for about 20 minutes the door opened and
we found two chairs in front of a bank
teller window type of thing with a
little slot presumably to exchange our
chips beyond the window was a bigger
room with several vertical wall panels
made up of great metal sheets there was
a door in the corner of the room and a
large mirror on each wall a bright disc
shaped light on the ceiling was the only
means of illumination someone stepped
into the room with us it was one of
their bottle girls she poured each of us
a glass and explained that tonight's
game would come in three parts
minimum that would be 15 credits and we
would be required to place a bet for
each game the first game would require
us to bet on who would hang in the
longest suddenly I felt a bit of a nasty
feeling as I thought about all the
warnings of moral values when it was
described to me I imagined something
along the lines of the board came sorry
where he had to bump off the other
players to win
I hadn't even anticipated the
possibility of a survival game so you
can imagine my relief when they willed 5
horizontal bars into the room beyond our
window I guess my wife had gotten the
same idea when they said who can hang in
the longest what came to your mind haha
I guess I thought we were sponsoring the
Hunger Games for a second there that's
when they marched 5 women completely
naked out onto the floor my wife glared
at me I told her I honestly had no idea
but she crossed her arms each of the
woman took their place under the bars my
immediate thought was that when I first
saw them they'd look tired and
disheveled they certainly didn't seem
happy to be there but given what I
thought the circumstances were a minute
ago it didn't bother me as much as it
should have so we just have to pick two
which one can hang on the bar the
longest seems easy the lightest one
should have the advantage second from
the right yeah but what about grip
strength how would we know what their
grip strength is like I don't know maybe
the one on the left maybe the one next
to her this feels so wrong it's like
we're slave traders up here or something
I could tell that she was half joking
but a small part of me did feel it was
wrong
sitting up here judging these exposed
women based on their bodies our drinks
were refilled and we were given a little
card without going into too much detail
the card contained odds and buy-in price
for each Kennedy our skinny candidate
had the best odds but that also meant
she had the biggest buy-in price so the
system they had here was kind of an
inverse from what you would expect from
a horse track or something similar
we still decided to go for a small chick
anyways I could feel the drink starting
to get to me as I counted out how many
chips I need to put in a bet on her
once the bets were in one more of the
casino employees went down into the room
and dumped a bucket of water onto the
floor the water spread evenly throughout
the room creating a shallow pool all the
way around what is that for
I don't know maybe it's to make it
obvious if someone touches the ground to
be honest I really had no idea but soon
I would find out the competition began
and all five ladies jumped onto the bar
one of them immediately lost her handle
and came crashing to the ground her
scream was cut short by an electric buzz
she was flailing and freaking out on the
ground that's when I realized the true
intent of the groundwater it wasn't to
show Who I touched look round
I mean maybe it was but the main purpose
was a motivation to stay on the bar
there was some kind of an electric
current running through the water
probably not enough to kill but
definitely enough to pack a punch the
poor lady was screeching and desperately
trying to get back to the bar but she
didn't have what it takes to hold on she
kept [ __ ] and getting shocked then
trying to pull herself back up before
falling again it was hard to watch after
about twenty seconds the girl next to
her went down and it looked like the
search that went through her was even
more violence she however was able to
get back up onto the bar and wrap her
legs around it in order to avoid further
pain the first woman just wasn't able to
pull herself up though molly was having
difficulty stomaching what she was
seeing
she grabbed my hand and gave me a
helpless look of concerned let's get out
of here
we headed for the exit but the door was
locked
hey we're done let us out but we were
reminded that we had agreed to stay for
the entire game and I realized that not
only would we have to sit there but we'd
also have to place bets and continue to
support the degrading inhumane
experiences that were going on down
there what had I gotten us into another
girl fell and got a short jolt of
electricity before hopping and wrapping
her legs around the bar for safety it
came down to two final girls our girl on
the more muscular looking girl I'd
suggested earlier our girl started to
lose her grip and shifted around to
regain her position but a couple of
seconds later she was wobbling again she
cried out and actually burst into tears
while still holding on to the bar
I guess she already knew she was going
to lose but continued to hold on for as
long as possible before long she slipped
and I could actually hear her yell out
as she did so luckily she only had a few
seconds of voltage the current seemed to
shut off and the last woman led herself
down from the bar and safety the whole
thing was maybe a minute and a half but
the first two have fallen wasn't paying
for all of that she was alive but she
didn't get up right away
her hair was literally standing up in
all directions and her skin was charred
like something out of a cartoon it was
just disgusting to watch our barrack but
that's probably not a strong enough word
to describe the pain she must have been
in eventually the room was cleared and a
water vacuum was used to dry things up
as the bars were taken out in
preparation of the next game they ended
up bringing out these big white yellow
rulers about four feet in length and
placing them against the wall when they
brought the women back out they had on
nothing but these knee-high boots which
subsequently latched into the wall at
the knee and at the toe so their shins
were pretty much locked in parallel to
the wall our drinks were refilled we
were given another card simply labeled
flexibility like before it gave us odds
and a-buyin price for each contestant I
noticed that some of them were the same
but if he had been swapped out the final
two girls from the last game were still
in there we again come to play
not betting we stalled for a few minutes
hoping they would just start the game
without our bet the bottle goal came
back and told us there had been a change
and exchanged the card we had for
another card the only difference was he
added one more contestant again we tried
to wait it out without betting but we
were interrupted by a bouncer who burst
into the room and told us that we had to
hurry up and make a bet we tried to
explain that we were no longer
comfortable with it but it did not help
I realized our best option was just to
finish the game and not come back we
soon realized there were only two
contestants out of the six that we can
even afford with the chips we had left
and they were the bottom two in terms of
odds we went with the cheapest one
wanting to support this heinous game as
little as possible the game started and
the object was the Bennis far back as
possible in a bridge position the score
was measured by how close they could get
their hands to their heels
it didn't seem like this game would be
nearly as brutal as the last one but I
was unfortunately surprised how close it
came I saw contortions I didn't even
think we're possible
all the contestants were able to see
each other and each of them seemed to be
trying their hardest if there was some
kind of external motivator in this game
like there was in the last one I
couldn't see what it was but I could
tell none of them wanted to loops it got
to the point that one of the girls was
pushing herself so hard that she
screamed out and collapsed onto the
floor and she wasn't able to go any
further as they continued to strain
there were two clear leaders the petite
girl on the more buff looking one who
were the final two in the previous round
this time a smaller girl came out on top
and her rival slammed her hand on the
floor in frustration
round two was over only one to go the
ladies were pushed to the breaking point
but I was just glad we got through that
one with no one's back being broken it
wasn't even the worst thing in the world
I was hoping that the final round would
be more tame and we could get out of
there with somewhat of a lantern
conscience hopefully we'd be able to
suppress this night and enjoy the rest
of our vacation after this that all went
out the window with what happened next
five men came into the room each
carrying a long-nosed rifle gun but
before you ask no known was shot during
the game but I didn't know that at the
time that's not to say what actually
ended up going down wasn't horrifying
though the barrel of each of these guns
was painted with a series of rainbow
colors stripes stretching from the tip
of the gun inwards
I didn't understand what the meaning of
this was until the bottle girl came out
and gave us the final card printed upon
it was the name of the last game an
iteration it looked at it in this belief
but before I could even begin to protest
molly pointed out that with the chips we
had left we couldn't even afford the
cheapest buy-in maybe this would
probably prompt them in kicking us out
we were more than ready to be done with
this place but after we once again
failed to place a bet the bouncer came
in to see what was up we explained our
situation and he told us we'd have to
get more chips and told my wife to come
with him minutes later he came back with
a velvet bag and handed it it was filled
with tons of chips way more than what we
ever had more than the guide to roulette
table or than we could ever probably
afford where's my wife I asked but he
was already gone that's when the bottle
girl came through one more time with
another card in hand and told me that
there's been a change I turned around
and looked into the window into the game
room and what I saw was more upsetting
and disturbing than anything I had laid
eyes upon that evening stripped down and
shaking with fear Molly had joined the
lineup of contestants
number three isolated getaway this isn't
easy for me to talk about if you've ever
tried to make long-term plans in a
relationship you'll probably know what
it's like my boyfriend and I had gone
out for two years and decided to plan a
relaxing little getaway
he never think that this kind of thing
would happen when you're planning our
trip but we ended up splitting up a
month and a half before ideally I would
have waited until after the vacation to
break up with him but when I caught him
fooling around with his physical
therapist I didn't even wait a day
before ending it
luckily for me I still had a suite
booked at the Grand Maritime Beach
Resort for whatever reason even though
he did all the research and booking the
reservation was made under both of our
names with my email address I figured it
would be a good consolation prize for
the suffering he put me through besides
I wasn't going to let him ruin my
much-needed time off he'd already done
enough damage I'd be enjoying this
vacation with or without him it felt
amazing to hop off the plane and stuff
my winter jacket into my back the rest
of the week I breezed through the
airport at the end of which a short
chubby guy asked me if I needed a ride I
told him that I was looking for the
Grand Maritime shuttle and it turned out
that he was the driver I guess I lucked
out because we didn't even have to wait
for other passengers I'd be enjoying
that sunshine before I knew it once we
arrived at the resort they told me my
room wasn't quite ready but they offered
to take my bags and let me enjoy the
pool and beach while they made the
preparations to be honest that's exactly
what I wanted I would worry about
unpacking later I got changed in the
bathroom and found myself a poolside
chair the resort was not at all when I
remembered my ex describing to me first
I expected more people I mean I was the
only one at the pool area it looked like
there was some more people by the beach
but it felt like it should have been
much more busy at this time of year
still I didn't mind some isolation and
time to myself it was also kind of a
shoddy place I remember it looking much
better in the photos leave it to my
stupid ex and not do the research who
cares though I was here catching some
Sun and not at work
a couple of loose pool tiles wouldn't
change that I decided to take a look
around the resort a bit again I was
pretty unimpressed actually it was kind
of creepy I felt as though it hadn't
been renovated since the 70s
and there was nobody around it was like
exploring the ruins of a forgotten old
resort there was a smaller pool that I
came across that was empty and filled
with moss the paintings on the wall were
cute or at least they might have been
several years ago but the paint had
chipped away so that the eyes of the
tribal figures were depicted just as
empty voids I felt more like I was in a
forbidden temple than a welcoming beach
resort corroded statues and broken
fences were just a couple more clues as
to why the place was so empty there was
even a boat on the beach that was turned
over in the sand gutted for parts and
covered in graffiti perhaps the
strangest part about it were the tiny
little speakers hidden in rocks around
the resort which were probably the only
evidence that the place was actually
operational I decided to just go back to
the pool in ten until my room was ready
while I waited one of the staff came up
to me and asked if I was interested in a
complimentary massage that sounded good
to me I followed him into a spa building
next to the pool I laid out facedown on
the massage table and he began to go to
work on my shoulders it was oddly quiet
no music or anything just the sound of
him breathing and kneading my flesh it
was a bit uncomfortable but at the same
time it felt so good so I tried to
ignore it then it got more uncomfortable
the guy just presumably unhooks my
bikini and goes to work on the part of
my back insides I don't usually get a
lot of massages but shouldn't he ask
before doing something like that then I
remembered why I was here and I thought
I should let myself live a little
someone else came into the room and
started talking to the masseuse in a
language I couldn't understand it
sounded like he was answering a bunch of
questions and he sounded kind of angry
his voice got louder as he came into the
room it sounded like he was right next
to my head so I opened my eyes and the
guy was right there staring at me
I panicked but I didn't quite know what
to do he started pacing around the room
talking to the guy I felt like his highs
were locked on to me my relaxation level
dropped fast and my nervousness level
was skyrocketing this guy was
unbelievable but then he actually
grabbed my butt I screamed out hey but I
couldn't fully turn away without
exposing myself I was just about ready
to be done with this massage why wasn't
the masseuse telling this creep to buzz
off the guy didn't let me go when I
yelled at him what the hell they just
carried on their conversation only
raising their voices so I started
kicking and thrashing my feet and
screaming at them to stop the only
problem was I could raise all the ruckus
I wanted but we all knew that there was
probably nobody out there to hear me I
tried to fight my way out but the
masseuse ended my struggle swiftly when
he dug his thumb somewhere into my
shoulders as hard as he could he must
have hit some pressure point or
something because that was the last
thing I remembered I was out I woke up
by the time I remembered what had
happened I realized that I was in a far
worse situation I was on a speedboat
sipping through the ocean accompanied by
only that strange man who had violated
me I could see the island off in the
distance and it was only getting further
and further away I jumped out of the
boat and swam as fast as I possibly
could I heard the engine died and the
driver turned around as soon as he
realized that was gone
before I knew it the boat was back in
front of me he told me it was stupid to
try to swim back and that it was further
than it looked and yanked me back into
the boat he was right I didn't have the
stamina to swim all the way back to
shore as I stared off at how far it
really was I saw a resort on the coast
that looked far nicer than my own why
couldn't my stupid ex have done his
research and booked that decent place
that's when I realized something the
sign displayed above the resort just
barely read in the distance
it said Grand Maritime Beach resumed
number four last resort I looked up and
saw a ship departing from the DA a
couple of jet ski riders zoomed by the
ships way even managing to catch a
little air that looked fun maybe I could
do a little bit of that later I dug my
toes into the warm sand and looked at my
watch it was 203 it seemed like as good
a time as any to grab myself a drink
after all the bar here at the grand
maritime was complimentary so why not
Lucy Lucy you okay I shook my sleeping
girlfriend shoulder lightly to see if
she wanted anything oh yeah I just fell
asleep what time is it about soon you
were tired you looked dead Thanks
I was just going up to the bar do you
want anything to drink you could grab me
a pina colada
I guess okay with that I kissed her and
headed off to the bar when I got back
with the drinks my girlfriend seemed to
have wandered off so I resumed my
position on the lounge chair and stared
off at the shoreline for a bit full of
hope that this was gonna be the best a
vacation ever
this was so nice about 15 minutes went
by Lucy still didn't show up ten minutes
more in another 15 minutes where had she
run off to
there was this old German couple at the
chairs behind us
I asked if they'd seen a blonde girl in
a black bikini sitting here and where
she might have headed off to they said
they had seen her talking to the survey
guy when I asked who the survey guy was
they told me he was going around from
chair to chair with a clipboard asking
people if they'd like to fill out a 15
minute satisfaction survey and that
they'd seen him talking to Lucy I asked
what direction they'd gone but neither
one of them was sure immediately I knew
something was wrong
Lucy was not the type to spend 15
minutes filling out a survey especially
on vacation
the next closest person was an
attractive young girl sipping on a
smoothy by herself
I asked her if she might have seen my
girlfriend possibly with a guy holding a
clipboard she told me she wasn't sure
about Lucy but she may have seen the
clipboard guy according to her he had
been going from chair to chair and had
asked her if she wanted to sign up for
some kind of island adventure thing but
she had politely declined apparently he
was really pushing it but she just
wasn't interested we were interrupted by
a guy who was about my age wearing long
swim trunks excuse me my apologies for
interrupting I just happened to overhear
that you say that you were looking for
your girlfriend
my wife seems to have disappeared off
this speech earlier this morning when I
ran back to the room to get some
sunscreen I've been looking all over and
haven't been able to find her yeah I
just went to the bar and came back she
was gone it's been almost an hour so I
started asking around why don't we both
investigate knowing my wife there's
probably some spa we don't know about
that they've both run off to yeah you're
probably right
let's go find him the girl I was talking
to said the guy with the clipboard was
headed down the beach to the left so we
continued that way my name is Mike by
the way Gary we continued asking around
one guy said that he'd seen the survey
guy come by but he told him he wasn't
interested
another couple said they hadn't seen
either of them then one chick said that
some guy had asked her to come down to
the activity Shack to sign up for some
kind of rainforest adventure and she'd
said no that's when I remembered lucy
and i checking into the hotel she found
this pamphlet with all of these
activities I think she told me she was
interested in doing some rainforest hike
or something Mike and I decided to look
for this activity Shack we headed down
the beach to the end of the resort's
property well Mike I guess this is where
we turn back I say we continue searching
down the beach for this supposed
activity Shack I've already searched
every inch of the resort for my wife I'm
convinced they're off property somewhere
I guess I walked down a bit further with
you I've got nothing to lose by checking
we continue down the beach until we
found an empty Shack it didn't look like
an activity Shack per se just more of a
little Hut before moving on
Mike noticed something in the same
he pulled up and dusted off a clipboard
there was one page on it an empty
spreadsheet with the words resort survey
crudely printed at the top we looked at
each other
Mike was wide-eyed he flipped over the
paper the back was completely different
a colored advertisement with bright
graphics of ziplining a campfire and a
waterfall something here didn't add up I
only saw two pairs of footsteps in the
sand heading back out of the activity
Shack instead of leading back to the
resort they led back inland toward a
street something was not right here Mike
and I headed to the street where some
sand was kicked up onto the pavement
someone had definitely jaywalked right
here so we headed across the street into
a rain forest we decided to spread out a
little bit and cover as much ground as
possible we made sure to stay within an
earshot of each other so when we
inevitably got lost at least we weren't
separated from each other Lucy Lucy it
seemed like we were totally alone in
this forest
it seemed useless I was about ready to
turn and go back they couldn't be out
here but that's when I heard Mike call
out to me Gary over here come quick my
heart joltin and I ran over him I was
looking around over here and I saw
something way off in the distance there
were three figures standing there two
men and a woman I was about to call out
to them when the two men jumped the lady
and knocked her out when they noticed me
staring they carried her into a car and
sped off I think it could have been your
girlfriend I felt a sharp pain of
nervousness and excitement in my chest
could it have been Lucy I wanted to be
close to finding her but I couldn't
stand the idea of her not being okay we
ran over there there was no real
evidence to speak of but there were tire
tracks that we could follow not only was
it our best bet of finding our women but
it was probably our only bet for finding
our way out of here we ended up
following these tracks for three
hours it was getting dark by the time we
came across a little campsite there was
a bonfire that had recently been put out
the wood was still charred and I could
smell smoke the tracks continued on from
there though and 30 minutes later we
were finally led out of the forest where
the tire marks continued on sand it was
a private little beach area hidden by
rocks in both sides we eventually
reached the end of the tracks where a
Jeep was parked in the sand near the
water and some footsteps led right into
the ocean itself shoot we wouldn't be
able to track them through the water and
there were so many different ways they
could have gone my heart ached as the
hope inside of me began to die I stared
into the same crystal blue waters that I
had just hours before but now with an
outlook of despair I felt like I was
never gonna see her again I looked over
to Mike I have an idea I'd never ridden
a jet ski before but I was gonna have to
learn quick it was easy enough to get
the hang of and I soon found myself
focusing more on looking for the boat
than worrying about the controls we were
back in front of the Grand Maritime
resort now there was a little speedboat
whipping across the current in the
distance a woman sat up and jumped off
of the boat she was thrashing in the
water swimming back towards the coast
the driver of the boat turned back and
pulled her back in did you see that yeah
that was weird let's keep an eye on them
so we did our best to follow this boat
making sure not to get too close or to
follow him too directly at any point we
Zig zagged our way around just staying
barely within eyeshot eventually the
boat pulled in next to a much larger
ship which was anchored out at sea the
guy tied a rope tethering him to the
larger ship and climbed aboard dragging
the woman with him
you park yours up next to the speedboat
or hard my along the other side of the
ship and swim back around to the side
that way if they see yours we'll have a
backup to escape on this was this if we
didn't find Lucy here and that was
probably never gonna see her again I
parked the jet ski and climbed onto the
boat we headed down a dark metal hallway
trying to keep our footsteps as quiet as
possible as we traveled down the sound
of music thumping from another room got
louder some kind of party was going on
on the other side of this wall
there was a door on the side or we could
just continue further down the hall into
the dark I decided to peek inside of the
door and opened it just a crack it was a
huge room dark with vibrant neon lights
tons of people dressed up sat at slot
machines and blackjack tables I quickly
and quietly closed the door hoping I
hadn't been noticed I nodded my head at
Mike to continue further down the
corridor which we couldn't see the end
of because of the dark Mike put his hand
out in front of me to stop he motioned
to his ear and I listened I could hear
breathing at the end of the hallway
there was no doubt that someone was
standing guard we knew he was there and
he knew we were here then as if to break
the silence and tension his voice called
out in the dark and told us we weren't
allowed back here
and to head back into the casino Mike
whispered for me to keep quiet then
spoke out to the guy excuse me sir I was
just looking for my wife
I believe she may had wandered back this
way the guard told him that nobody had
been through this way but Mike insisted
he double check we heard the door he was
guarding creak open and Mike dragged me
forward into the dark to where we could
see the end of the hall he yanked on the
door but it had automatically locked so
he hid in the corner behind the door
stand off
I'm white van to come through I could
see where Mike was going with this I
wasn't convinced it would work but I
couldn't come up with much better the
guard came back through the door and saw
me standing in the hall I said nothing
he told me that nobody had gotten back
there thanks the voice came from behind
him as Mike jumped on the guy's back
taking him by surprise before he had a
chance to close the door behind him I
bolted through the door and made it it's
slammed shut with a huge metallic Clank
I would be on my own from here on out
the room I found myself in was some kind
of lab there were several rows of
operation tables and these vertical
tubes with a blue glow emanating from
them I inspected the first one it seemed
to just be an empty water tank though it
did contain what looked like kind of a
scuba regulator at the end of a tube
before I could inspect any further I
heard a door being unlocked and I
quickly doh behind the tank to hide
please I just want to get my husband and
go back to my hotel hey what do you
think you're doing get your hands off me
two men who looked to be employees of
the casino slam this woman to the
operating table with her screaming all
the while I couldn't see fully what they
were doing to her from where I was but I
did see the man's pants drop at his
ankles and based on the screams I'm sure
you can guess the rest it was hard
enough to stand by and let this happen
but I also kept imagining my Lucy in the
same situation my fists were shaking
with rage I was creating my teeth and I
could barely contain myself still I had
the advantage of them not knowing I was
here and if I was gonna have any chance
I had to keep it that way the girl on
the table seemed to just give up the
fight and the man doing the thrusting
said 10 to 1 then spewed out a bunch of
different numbers as if he was some kind
of twisted odds maker then the girl now
stark naked was pushed out into another
room then the guy followed her out there
with a rifle go
whoa I was in way over my head I had no
way to defend myself against that I had
to find Lucy and get out of there
without getting caught the first guy
went into a different door and it looked
like he headed up some stairs I jumped
up to investigate the rest of the lab
there were more of these water tanks
stretching down the length of the room
what I found was that many of them
contained women again completely exposed
breathing through tubes I had recognized
one of them as the lady we'd seen jump
off the speed boat earlier the next girl
looked in much worse shape her skin
looked charred and her hair was standing
up in every direction my hope was
dwindling but what happened next I I
can't even explain the feeling that shot
through me it was Lucy I nearly blacked
out upon seeing her I was feeling every
emotion a person can feel all at once
her eyes were closed and she was just
gracefully floating there breathing
through a mask but definitely breathing
I knocked on the glass unsure of how to
get her out she didn't hear I knocked
harder and her I shot open you could
just see that they were immediately
filled with fear that she'd been
conditioned to expect abuse but once she
recognized me everything changed she put
her hand up to the glass and I reached
up and did the same once again I heard
the door unlock and I ducked into hiding
this time it was two men one looked like
it native to the island the other was a
foreigner both were wearing suits the
foreign guy had a drink in his hand he
was overweight and seemed to have a
breathing problem there was a metal tube
coming out of his neck that seemed to be
regulating his respiratory system to
understand the relevance of games 2 & 3
what was the point of the first game the
Islander guy responded simply to break
them or this one performed beautifully
a fine specimen indeed shell out for her
they started talking prices and times
that was it I couldn't stand by anymore
and watch this freaking guy [ __ ] out my
girlfriend I didn't care if I got myself
killed I couldn't sit there and hide
anymore I crawled out the guy didn't see
me I got a running start and knocked the
[ __ ] in the face full speed I shattered
my fists but I didn't even realize it at
the time before he knew I hit him I
grabbed the fat by the back of the neck
and crashed his face into the glass it
didn't budge but it must have set off
some kind of alarm and a red light
started flashing and thrust his face
into the glass two three four times
before it started to show a crack which
I noticed on the growing splosh of
liquid red now on the surface of the
window I've heard back one more time
with all my might and shattered the tank
on this guy's skull water washed out
everywhere with a greater force than I
had expected
Lucy went sliding across the lab floor
it helped her get to her feet but there
was no time for a heartfelt reunion we
ran for our lives as we exited I heard
the voices of yelling men behind us we
made it to the hall where I had left
guard I wasn't sure where the guard had
gone but it was clear but it happened to
Mike he was beaten to a pulp and left
sprawled on the floor there was no time
to mourn if we were lucky we might just
get out alive we made it to the hatch
somehow I was able to pry it open we
were back into the open air almost
home-free
but what waited on the other side would
be possibly my toughest challenge yet
the guard who had beaten up Mike was
standing over the jet ski I had pulled
up in which was on fire and he continued
to pour on the gasoline he turned around
in socks not knowing what else to do I
pushed him hoping to catch him off
balance or something and somehow it
worked
he went crashing down into the flaming
vehicle before falling into the water I
had no idea if he'd gotten to the other
jetski but it was our only hope this way
I took my girlfriend's hand and jumped
out into the ocean we swam like there
was no tomorrow where are we going the
ship billowed its horn over and over I
began to fear it might be a distress
call still if we got to the jet ski that
probably wasn't much they could do to
catch us this was it it all came down to
the escape we turned the corner around
the outside of the ship to where Mike's
jet ski should have been but it was gone
so that's it then it was all for nothing
there what's that over there
often the distance was Mike's jet ski it
had just drifted away from the ship it
was a long swim but we made it
the rest of the night was mostly a blur
I don't remember much of when we crashed
into the shore terrifying the tourists
who are enjoying the ocean and moonlight
I don't remember the trip to the
emergency room but I do remember when
the pain of what they had done to me
finally set in the police came to talk
to us as did some representatives from
the resort the casino was in
international waters
so it was out of the jurisdiction of the
law but they told us they were doing
everything they could do to stop
abductions on the land and keep tourists
informed on the dangers of gambling
offshore they had warnings posted all
over the island but that didn't stop
people from being drawn to the thrill
and they would find other ways to lure
people in the resort wasn't involved in
any of this but of course they told us
they would be striving to improve their
security on the beach and make sure
people knew what dangers lie beyond
their walls they were kind enough to pay
our medical bill and we wouldn't have to
worry about paying for our stay either
they even offered a free week at the
resort at a time of our choosing but I
already knew we would never be coming
back the pain of my broken hand was
really starting to set in the police
wanted to know more about Mike and his
wife but we didn't have much information
to help them other than the fact that
his wife was still out there
I asked if trafficking had always been a
problem on this island
his response made everything that had
happened that night seemed even scarier
he scoffed at me and said if only it was
just trafficking
[Applause]
thanks for listening to all daint a
creepypasta your total today comes out
to $4,000 but if you like this video
right now I'll waive that fee and give
you everything you just listen to
complimentary all-inclusive I was joined
this time by a tirade of talented
narrators including black eyed blonde
that spooky guy eden lady white rabbit
and mortise media if you liked all date
a creepypasta I'd recommend each of
their channels I'll leave links to their
work in the description please take the
time to visit their channels I'd also
like to give thanks to cold gray for
voicing the foreign buyer he's actually
a comedy channel and he's got great
stuff you gotta go check him out as
always thank aSTHO for putting together
the incredible store and naolia Saku
monza for the end theme you're hearing
right now let me know which stories were
your favorite this time and if you like
how we tied this one together this is
essentially gonna be the end of season
one there will be a compilation episode
coming shortly but then we'll be digging
right into season 2 so if you want to
support the channel you can do so by
simply picking up something at the merch
store I recently launched this hashtag
keep YouTube creepy line and a few of
the narrator's yard today are featured
on that if you haven't already remember
to subscribe the Seas world for new
Horrors every week bring that death Bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one
assuming we both survive
you
[Music]